ah
[Música]
esta charla la escribí y la reescribir
decenas de veces porque la realidad fue
superando la ficción en lo que a
pandemia e información se refiere cuanto
mejor estábamos con respecto al comida
más fec news fake news todos saben son
noticias falsas pero es mucho más que
eso prefiero llamar la desinformación y
la desinformación muchas veces no tienen
nada que ver con la noticia por ejemplo
el otro día estaba en una reunión y
escuché decir la pandemia nunca existió
por suerte al otro día abro el diario y
veo una nota titulada la pandemia nunca
existió que explicaban qué es lo que
pasa esta nota que dice aunque parezca
extraño se trata de un acontecimiento
despiadado es un mecanismo de negación
que es una estrategia potente para
esquivar el dolor de diferentes
situaciones que nos generan traumas como
la pandemia que nos afectó económica y
afectivamente
eso me llevó a querer hablar de esto
porque teníamos una vida más o menos
normal y de pronto empezamos a ver cómo
en españa' salían a aplaudir a los
balcones al personal médico enfermeros
de pronto éramos
empáticos y solidarios y después nos
tocó a nosotros nos tuvimos que encerrar
y en las diferentes ciudades de la
argentina también salimos a aplaudir a
las 9 de la noche a los médicos y
enfermeros cuánto nos duró nada lo mismo
que nos llevó naturalizar la muerte le
empezamos a contar por día 50 85
300 500 mil 500 muertos 100 mil muertos
tan intenso era que si no nos tocaba de
cerca no lo veíamos que hicimos me
parece que a todos les habrá pasado lo
mismo
intentamos no escuchar sobre el comido
apagamos las noticias la tele y nos
pusimos a ver netflix todos vimos acá
estoy segura poco ortodoxa y gambito de
dama
y aunque hayamos hecho todo el esfuerzo
por evitarlo
igual no llego en un año y medio a todos
se nos murieron familiares amigos el
diariero del almacén de la otra cuarta
de la otra cuadra era tan intenso que no
podíamos escapar le desde marzo del 2020
todo cambio para nosotros pero sobre
todo nos contaminamos con otro virus que
es el virus del odio y que tiene que ver
justamente con la fec news y con
internet y todos los que nos generan a
veces este virus del odio tiene la
máscara de un troll desconocido que tpa
en la oscuridad de internet otra con
algunos personajes siniestros de medios
de comunicación o de la política y
muchas veces tiene que ver con las
noticias que consumen nuestros
familiares y amigos y les pregunto con
cuánta gente se distanciaron a partir
del comida
en mi caso también pasé de no querer
saber nada y no angustiarme con la
situación que por supuesto no sabíamos
cuánto iba a durar a tener que informar
sobre el tema porque después de mucho
desearlo entré en un trabajo a donde
tenía que informar pero no de tecnología
que es mi especialidad sino de comida y
vacunas yo me resistí pero la realidad
nos rodeaba esto fue en febrero del 2021
entonces empecé a informarme a informar
a hacer entrevistas a consultar expertos
y así en un círculo de autocuidado que
en mi vida consistió muchos meses en ir
de mi casa al trabajo y del trabajo a mi
casa informando todos los días cuántos
fallecidos como subía y bajaba la curva
no solamente en argentina sino en chile
en uruguay en europa cuáles eran los
avances de la vacuna y también consistió
en un momento en ir como notera como
movilera a los vacunatorios porque el
antídoto había llegado todo esto con el
vértigo de estar en el peor momento de
la pandemia sin vacuna ni yo ni mis
compañeros pero de la tristeza de la
muerte pasamos a la alegría de las
vacunas y a conocer lo peor de la gente
la trampa de querer vacunarse antes
luchando un certificado médico o
poniendo otra localidad para hacerlo más
rápido o criticar todo cualquier avance
médico o científico o logístico en el
medio de una pandemia mundial que nos
afecta a todos y lo peor difundir videos
fakes e información delirante que decía
que la vacuna tenía un chip sin coge
adentro o que te emplean todos metales
por los cuales se te pegaban cucharas en
el brazo y otra información no tan
delirante pero certera que decía que la
vacuna por ejemplo el astra zéneca te
puede generar trombosis pero esto sí
bien no es tan delirante es muy
temerario porque el riesgo de que la
vacuna te de trombosis es de 100 04 %
muchísimo menor del riesgo que podemos
tener de tener trombosis si fumamos si
tomamos un avión si tomamos una píldora
anticonceptiva o si contrae moskovitz es
de un
14%
todo esto generó mucho malestar
en la población y tiene que ver con las
noticias falsas que podemos hacer al
respecto informarnos ser más conscientes
y aprender a chequear información saben
lo que lleva a chequear una información
y saben lo que lleva a decir cualquier
cosa es inversamente proporcional a
difundir un affair news
se hace muy rápidamente y desmentirla
lleva muchísimo más tiempo hoy según un
informe de gartner consumimos más
mentiras que verdad es más sale mucho
más barato hacer noticias falsas que
verdaderas porque no hay que chequear
nada entonces yo le voy a compartir
algunas estrategias para saber cómo
hacemos así como para cocinar una torta
sabemos que tener que tenemos que poner
huevos harina agua y el horno caliente
para consumir información podemos tener
algunas herramientas en cuenta una es la
estrategia pibe que tiene que ver con
las letras de la palabra pibe y es pare
investigue
busque los nexos y de dónde surge la
noticia esto es muy fácil si estamos
viendo una imagen y no sabemos a qué
corresponde hacemos clic derecho
buscamos en google a donde de dónde
pertenece la primera foto y sabemos que
no es una foto nueva por ejemplo o
buscamos alguna relación establecemos en
la aedep y ve algún nexo con la fuente
original de información y nos vamos a
dar cuenta si es verdad o no otra
estrategia es
al silencio no hay que opinar de todos y
por supuesto no tenemos que compartir
algo que sabemos que es falso y que se
lo compartimos va a generar malestar y
por otro lado tratar de decir siempre la
verdad y evitar decir la mentira no
repetir y hay dos técnicas acá intentar
no decir la palabra no es intentar
afirmar la falsedad por sobre la mentira
y aquí viene otra técnica que me pareció
genial que se llama el sandwich de la
verdad es el autor del libro no pienses
en un elefante de george lakoff y
consiste en enmarcar a la mentira entre
dos verdades entonces el marco principal
a que estamos viendo la verdad es por
ejemplo la vacuna contra el cob y de
seguro la mentira lo que queremos
desmentir que es que la vacuna no es
segura y afirmamos nuevamente la vacuna
segura porque hay hasta hace años que
estamos investigando los diferentes
científicos la vacuna y esto establece
un marco de verdad entonces esto nos
permite tener algunas herramientas para
las noticias verdaderas y dejar de lado
las noticias falsas estas son algunas de
las técnicas y estos son algunos de los
mitos que tienen que ver contra la
vacuna del cob y de con respecto a los
medios de comunicación se suele decir
que todos mienten pero en realidad acá
el veneno no son las vacunas el veneno
es la información falsa acá el problema
tiene que ver con algo que se conoce
como hate news y que son noticias de
odio esas que nos generan ira y que no
apuntan a informar sino que apuntan a
generar emociones temerarias contra la
salud pública y se basan en dos cosas se
basan en estar en contra de los
gobiernos y en contra de la ciencia de
hecho las naciones unidas llamó a este
fenómeno de infodema entonces lo que yo
propongo es más allá de vacunarnos estar
informados y ser solidarios como el 90%
de los argentinos mayores de 18 años que
ya a vacunarse es ser conscientes de
todos los mecanismos de manipulación que
suceden en los medios y para investigar
y difundir información verdadera o sino
hacer silencio termino esta charla
pensando un poco esto esta información
la semana que se comunicó que iban a
vacunar a los niños y niñas mayores de 3
años y se me pianta un lagrimón el mismo
que se me plantó cuando me di la primera
y la segunda dosis y elijo creer que
estamos en un mundo más seguro porque
batman spiderman y la mujer maravilla
están vacunados
[Aplausos]
[Música]